TOUGH ON TERRORISTS.
ED HENRY HAS A FULL REPORT.
THAT'S ALL IN TONIGHT'S BREAKING
NEWS OPENING MONOLOGUE.
ALL RIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S KEY CAMPAIGN
PROMISE, BUILD THAT WALL, TAKES
A MAJOR STEP FORWARD TODAY.
THE PRESIDENT TOURED BORDER WALL
PROTOTYPES DURING A VISIT TO
SAN DIEGO, CALIFORNIA.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF YOU DON'T HAVE A WALL
SYSTEM, YOU'RE GOING -- WE'RE
NOT GOING TO HAVE A COUNTRY.
THERE'S A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN
MEXICO.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF PROBLEMS OVER
THERE.
THEY HAVE THE CARTELS AND THE
CARTELS WE'RE FIGHTING THE
CARTELS AND FIGHTING THEM HARD.
NOBODY EVER FOUGHT THEM LIKE WE
FOUGHT THEM.
WE'RE LOOKING VERY MUCH AT THE
WALL WITH SOME SEE-THROUGH
CAPABILITY ON THE OTHER SIDE AND
SOLID CONCRETE ON TOP OR STEEL
AND CONCRETE ON TOP.
THE ROUND PIECE THAT YOU SEE
HERE OR YOU SEE CLEARLY BACK
THERE, THE LARGER IT IS THE
BETTER IT IS BECAUSE IT'S HARD
TO GET OVER THE TOP.
IT'S REALLY A DETERRENT FROM
GETTING OVER THE TOP.
WHO WOULD THINK.
GETTING OVER THE TOP IS EASY.
THESE ARE LIKE PROFESSIONAL
MOUNTAIN CLIMBERS.
THEY'RE INCREDIBLE CLIMBERS.
SOME OF THEM THEY CAN'T CLIMB.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT STRESSED
THE NEED FOR MUCH TIGHTER BORDER
SECURITY DURING A SPEECH AT A
NAVAL BASE IN SAN DIEGO.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
>> DANGEROUS CRIMINAL AND
TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS SEEK TO
EXPLOIT OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
I'VE JUST COME FROM A TRIP TO
THE BORDER WHERE I MET WITH OUR
WONDERFUL BORDER AGENTS, BORDER
PATROL AND THE ICE AGENTS.
UNBELIEVABLE PEOPLE.
AND REVIEWED PROTOTYPES OF A NEW
PHYSICAL WALL THAT WILL PROTECT
OUR BORDER AND PROTECT OUR
COUNTRY.
BUT THAT WALL WILL STOP SO MUCH.
WE LOOKED AT THE DIFFERENT
PROTOTYPES.
IT WAS FASCINATING.
WE HAVE TWO OR THREE THAT REALLY
WORK.
WE HAD PEOPLE TRYING TO SCALE.
WE'VE DONE THEM EVERY WAY.
I'M A BUILDER.
WHAT I DO BEST IS BUILD.
OKAY?
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT IS
BLASTING THE LIBERAL BASTION OF
CALIFORNIA AND JERRY BROWN AND
THE LIBERAL MAYOR OF OAKLAND FOR
CHAMPIONING SANCTUARY POLICIES
THAT PUT CRIMINAL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BEFORE AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND THEIR SAFETY.
WATCH THIS.
>> I THINK GOVERNOR BROWN HAS
DONE A POOR JOB OF RUNNING
CALIFORNIA.
THEY HAVE THE HIGHEST TAXES IN
THE UNITED STATES.
THE PLACE IS OUT OF CONTROL.
YOU HAVE SANCTUARY CITIES,
CRIMINALS LIVING IN THE
SANCTUARY CITIES.
AND THEN THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND
NOTIFIES WHEN ICE IS PICKING UP
CRIMINALS WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS
AND DANGEROUS PEOPLE.
YOU'D SAY DANGEROUS PEOPLE.
NO, I THINK THE GOVERNOR IS
DOING A TERRIBLE JOB RUNNING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
>> Sean: SO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS LITERALLY PUTTING
AMERICAN LIVES IN DANGER.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY WON'T FOLLOW THE
LAW, COOPERATE WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION OFFICIALS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO THEIR JOB.
ARREST ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CRIMINALS AND REMOVE THEM FROM
THE COUNTRY.
THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE.
DEMOCRATS SADLY ARE PUTTING
POLITICS AND SUBJECTING
AMERICANS TO UNNECESSARY
DANGERS.
IF ONE AMERICAN IS THE VICTIM OF
A CRIME COMMITTED BY PEOPLE THAT
HAVE NO BUSINESS HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT WE KNOW COMMITTED
OTHER DEMOCRATS, DEMOCRATS IN
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE TO OWN
THAT.
WHAT IS SO DESPICABLE ABOUT THIS
IS DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO LIE AND
MISREPRESENT THE FACTS WHEN IT
COMES TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CRIME.
HERE HAY COUPLE OF STATISTICS
THAT THE LEFT IN THIS COUNTRY
DON'T WANT YOU TO KNOW ABOUT.
ACCORDING TO THE MIGRATION
POLICY INSTITUTE.
820,000 OF 11 MILLION ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN AMERICA ARE
CONVICTED CRIMINALS.
THE U.S. SENTENCING COMMISSION
HAS FOUND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ACCOUNT FOR 13% OF
NONIMMIGRATION-RELATED FEDERAL
SENTENCING DURING THE FISCAL
YEAR 2016.
THAT'S DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THESE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ONLY
MAKE UP 3.5% OF THE POPULATION.
IT IS A STUNNING NUMBER AND THAT
NUMBER ONLY RELATES TO FEDERAL
SENTENCES.
IT'S MUCH HIGHER WHEN YOU
INCLUDE CONVICTIONS BY STATE AND
LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
IT'S BEYOND SHAMEFUL THAT THE
LEFT DEMOCRATS, JERRY BROWN, THE
OAKLAND MAYOR, IGNORED THE DATA
THAT IS OUT THERE AND THEY
CONTINUE TO PROTECT CRIMINAL
IMMIGRANTS.
LIBERALS HAVE NO CLUE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS AT THE BORDER.
I'VE BEEN DONE THERE.
WE HAVE SHOWN YOU.
I'VE BEEN FROM THE RIO GRANDE,
SAN DIEGO, ON HORSEBACK,
ALL-TERRAIN VEHICLES.
LOOK AT ME RIDING A HORSE.
WE'VE BEEN ON ALL OVER.
BOATS AND EVERYTHING.
I'VE SEEN THE ARRESTS OF GANG
MEMBERS.
I'VE SEEN THE DRUG TUNNELS AND
THE WAREHOUSES AND EVERYTHING IN
BETWEEN.
IN 2014, I SAT IN ON BORDER
BRIEFING ABOUT SECURITY WITH TOX
GOVERNOR RICK PERRY.
IN A SEVEN-YEAR PERIOD, ILLEGALS
COMMITTED 642,000 CRIMES AGAINST
TEXANS ALONE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO PUT THE
SAFETY OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST?
WATCH THIS.
>> THE CRIMINALS HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR 642,000 CRIMINAL
OFFENSES.
LOOK UP THERE IN THE TOP LEFT.
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
CLOSE TO 8,000 VICTIMS.
>> 642,000 CRIMES --
>> SINCE 2008.
>> IN TEXAS.
IN TEXAS ALONE.
>> YES, SIR.
>> OVER 200,000.
>> INDIVIDUALS, THEIR CRIMINAL
HISTORY REFLECTS THAT THEY WERE
COMMITTING OVER 642,000 CRIMES.
>> THAT'S THE COST OF NOT
SECURING THE BORDER.
>> Sean: THAT'S THE TRUTH ABOUT
ILLEGAL CRIME IN THIS COUNTRY.
NUMBER 1, THEY DON'T LIE.
THE LEFT DOES LIE.
THAT'S SAD.
WE SENT A PRODUCER TODAY TO TALK
TO PROTESTERS THAT WERE GATHERED
OUTSIDE OF THE AREA WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS REVIEWING
THE PROTOTYPE WALLS.
LISTEN TO WHAT THE PROTESTERS
SAY.
[CHANTING].
>> DO WE HAVE AN IMMIGRATION
PROBLEM IN THE UNITED
>> NO.
>> NO?
>> HUMAN BEINGS HAVE WANDERED
THE WORLD SINCE -- FOREVER,
SINCE THEY CRAWLED OUT OF THE
SWAMP.
>> I IMMIGRATED 40 SOMETHING
YEARS AGO FROM ONE OF THOSE
[BLEEP] HOLE COUNTRIES OF
TRUMP'S.
I'M A VERY PROUD AMERICAN.
I'M HERE EXERCISING MY RIGHT TO
DISAGREE WITH HIM.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN YOU COULD
WALK ACROSS BACK AND FORTH TO
TIJUANA AND SAN DIEGO.
AND I THINK THINGS WERE BETTER
THEN.
>> I THINK DONALD TRUMP IS THE
MOST DANGEROUS THING TO HAPPEN
TO OUR COUNTRY.
I HATE TO SAY IT, SINCE WORLD
WAR II AND HITLER.
>> Sean: REALLY?
HERE'S ANOTHER PIECE OF KEY
INFORMATION THE LEFT WANTS TO
KEEP SECRET FROM YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE LIKE TO TELL YOU THE TRUTH
ACCORDING TO THE CENTER FOR
IMMIGRATION STUDIES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S $18 BILLION
BORDER WALL, IT WOULD PAY FOR
ITSELF BY REDUCING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT CRIME.
THAT MEANS DRUGS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER, REDUCING THE NUMBER
OF FEDERAL BENEFITS GOING TO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THAT DON'T
RESPECT OUR SOVEREIGNTY, DON'T
RESPECT OUR LAWS.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE HAVE NEW BOMB
SHELL INFORMATION ABOUT THAT
CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
DOSSIER.
A NEW BOOK CALLED "RUSSIAN
ROULETTE."
IT'S MEANT TO SMEAR PRESIDENT
TRUMP BUT INSTEAD, IT'S
CONFIRMING VERY KEY PIECES OF
INFORMATION THAT WE'VE BEEN
TELLING YOU ABOUT.
THE DAILY CALLER OBTAINED THIS
BOOK.
THEY REPORTED THAT BARACK
OBAMA'S 2012 CAMPAIGN -- THIS IS
FASCINATING -- THEY PAID FUSION
GPS $3 MILLION FOR OP RESEARCH
ON MITT ROMNEY.
THE OBAMA CAMPAIGN, THEY WERE
ABLE TO HIDE IT -- GET THIS --
BY FUNNELING PAYMENTS TO FUSION
GPS THROUGH THAT LAW FIRM,  THAT
HILLARY USED.
THIS IS THE EXACT SAME THING
THAT HILLARY CLINTON DID EXCEPT
SHE AND THE DNC DIDN'T PAY $3
MILLION.
THEY PAID OVER $12 MILLION THAT
USED RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT SOURCES
AND LIES AND PROPAGANDA.
THE DAILY CALLER IS REPORTING ON
ANOTHER PIECE OF INFORMATION
FROM THE BOOK.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, FORMER SPY,
OPENLY DOUBTED HIS OWN DOSSIER
TO HIS FRIENDS.
ESPECIALLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PIECES OF FAKE NEWS FROM THE
DOSSIER, HE HAD NO CLUE IF IT'S
TRUE.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE COMPLETELY
RIDICULOUS STILL NEVER VERIFIED
FABRICATED STORY ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP AND HOOKERS AT A RITZ
CARLTON IN MOSCOW URINATING IN
THE BED.
SO STEELE DIDN'T THINK IT WAS
TRUE.
HE INCLUDED IT ANYWAY.
HILLARY BROUGHT IT.
SHE GAVE TO IT THE FBI.
THEY DIDN'T DO THEIR JOB.
THEY NEVER VERIFIED OR
CORROBORATED.
IT'S NOT ONLY PROTOCOL BUT WHAT
THE FISA LAW TELLS THEM TO DO.
THEN THEY USED IT TO SECURE A
FISA WARRANT, THE SAME THING
THAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE DIDN'T
EVEN BELIEVE, TO SPY ON AN
OPPOSITE PARTY CANDIDATE IN AN
ELECTION YEAR.
THEY NEVER TOLD THE FISA JUDGE
THAT THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN AND
THE DNC PAID FOR THESE
UNVERIFIED LIES AND NOBODY HAD
ANY CLUE AT ALL THE IT WAS TRUE.
THE DAILY CALLER IS IDENTIFYING
A KEY SOURCE BEHIND THE RITZ
CARLTON CLAIM.
TURNS OUT IT'S A FOREIGN
BUSINESS MAN.
THE THING IS SERGEI IS TELLING
THE DAILY CALLER THAT THE
DOSSIER IS "GARBAGE NEWS."
THAT WASN'T HARD TO FIGURE OUT.
WHY DIDN'T THE FBI DO IT?
THE WASHINGTON TIMES REPORTING
ON ANOTHER MAJOR REVELATION IN
THE BOOK.
SENIOR OBAMA STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL, VICTORIA NEWLAND GAVE
THE ORIGINAL APPROVAL FOR AN FBI
AGENT TO MEET WITH CHRISTOPHER
STEELE ABOUT THE FAKE NEWS
DOSSIER.
THAT MEANS THAT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WAS DIRECTLY
INVOLVED.
WE ALSO REACHED OUT TO NEWLAND
FOR COMMENT.
HER SPOKESPERSON GOT BACK TO US
BUT NEVER DISTRICTED US.
WE WERE JUST DISTRICTED TOO OLD
INTERVIEWS.
THIS NEW REVELATION IS A KEY
PIECE OF INFORMATION.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT STARTED THE ENTIRE
PROCESS OF SPYING ON A TRUMP
CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE AND THEN
ULTIMATELY THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
SO HOW IS IT POSSIBLE -- THINK
ABOUT THIS -- IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA, THE FBI NEVER
CORROBORATED THIS PHONY DOSSIER
WITH RUSSIAN LIES?
IT VIOLATED ITS OBSERVE
PROTOCOLS, THE FISA LAW ITSELF.
THIS IS A MASSIVE ABUSE OF
POWER.
AND BY THE WAY, THE FULL SCOPE
OF THIS IS ONLY SLOWLY BEING
REVEALED.
IT'S ONLY BECAUSE A FEW OF US
ARE WORKING HARD TO GET YOU THE
TRUTH.
THERE'S MORE EXPLOSIVE
INFORMATION THAT IS GOING TO
COME OUT IN TIME.
SO I SAY TO EVERYBODY OUT THERE,
TICK TOK, STAY WITH US.
FINALLY TONIGHT, RANKING
DEMOCRATIC MEMBER ON THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE, ADAM SCHIFF, WE
KNOW HE'S PROVEN TO BE A LIAR
FOR OVER A YEAR NOW.
HE'S BEEN ORCHESTRATING NOTHING
SHORT OF A PROPAGANDA
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO DELEGITIMIZE
HIM AND HOPEFULLY TAKE HIM OUT
OF OFFICE.
BY THE WAY, VLADIMIR PUTIN WOULD
BE PROUD OF THE WORK THAT SCHIFF
IS DOING.
THE RUSSIAN'S MAIN GOAL WAS TO
SOW POLITICAL DISCORD.
THAT'S WHAT CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF
HAS BEEN DOING IN THIS COUNTRY
NONSTOP.
EVEN THOUGH HE'S KNOWN THE
ENTIRE TIME NO EVIDENCE, NO
PROOF WHATSOEVER OF RUSSIA-TRUMP
COLLUSION.
TAKE A LOOK AT SCHIFF'S
EVOLUTION OVER TIME ON THIS
ISSUE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT DO YOU HAVE --
>> CHRIS, I CAN'T GO INTO THE
EVIDENCE --
>> DO YOU HAVE SOMETHING HARD
THAT YOU CAN'T REVEAL?
>> I CAN'T REVEAL THAT, CHRIS.
>> OF COURSE THERE'S ONE THING
TO SAY THERE'S EVIDENCE.
THERE'S ANOTHER THING TO SAY WE
CAN PROVE THIS OR PROVE IT
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT OR
ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO BRING FOR A
GRAND JURY.
>> I DON'T THINK WE CAN SAY
ANYTHING DEFINITIVELY AT THIS
POINT.
>> LAST MARCH YOU SAID YOU HAD
MORE THAN CIRCUMSTANTIAL ED OF
TREASONOUS COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
WHAT WERE YOU REFERRING TO?
BE SPECIFIC.
IF IT'S TRUE, AMERICANS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW A YEAR LATER WHAT
THAT IS.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WELL, I CERTAINLY SAID THAT
THERE'S AMPLE EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
I NEVER USED THE WORD "TREASON."
ONLY STEVE BANNON HAS USED THAT
WORD.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS THAT
ARE ALREADY IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN, THEY'RE PRETTY DAMMING.
>> THAT MEAN HE HAS NO PROOF.
GOOD I DON'T KNOW, MEGAN McCAIN.
AND SCHIFF IS A NATIONAL
EMBARRASSMENT AND SELECTIVELY
BEEN LEAKING LIKE A FAUCET TO
TRY TO DAMAGE AND DISCREDIT
WITNESSES THAT APPEAR BEFORE THE
HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE.
AFTER REPUBLICANS REACHED THEIR
FINDINGS, SCHIFF RACES OVER TO
CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC WHERE HE
WANTS A JOB TO SPIN A NEW
NARRATIVE.
BECAUSE THE OLD NARRATIVE DIDN'T
WORK.
WATCH THIS.
>> IT BECAME APPARENT EARLY ON,
FROM ALMOST A YEAR AGO WITH THE
MIDNIGHT RUN TO THE WHITE HOUSE,
THE REPUBLICANS ON THE COMMITTEE
VIEWED THEIR JOB AS PROTECTING
THE PRESIDENT, NOT INVESTIGATING
WHAT TOOK PLACE.
ESSENTIALLY IT'S THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE MAJORITY
SAYING WE JUST RATHER NOT KNOW
IF IT'S GOING TO BE BAD NEWS.
THAT IS A BETRAYAL OF THE
PROMISE THAT WAS MADE THAT WE
WOULD FOLLOW THE FACTS WHEREVER
THEY LEAD.
>> Sean: 14 MONTHS YOU'VE BEEN
INVESTIGATING THIS AT THE INTEL